el cohete italiano Vega Se tardó dos
minutos y 27 segundos en fracasar en su
misión lanzado con éxito empezó a
desviarse de su trayectoria y se
perdieron las comunicaciones
a cargo arian space empresa líder en el
lanzamiento de satélites dijo que se
produjo una anomalía en el sefiro 40 en
la segunda etapa del despegue No se han
encontrado restos y no han podido
localizar el cohete ve así va a poner en
órbita dos satélites de observación
construidos por airbus y unirse a playa
Neo 5 y 6 capaces de captar varias veces
al día imágenes de alta calidad de
cualquier lugar de la tierra un enorme
revés para el programa especial europeo
ya que Vegas se debía aumentar el acceso
de Europa al espacio tras verse obligada
dejar de utilizar los vehículos soyuz a
causas de la invasión de Ucrania la esta
tuvo que recurrir al gigante
estadounidense space six para lanzar dos
misiones científicas al fundador de
spacy
reaccionó en Twitter
Lamento oír esto es un recordatorio
aleccionador de la dificultad de los
vuelos espaciales orbitales pero la esta
a la agencia especial europea se queda
ahora sin acceso a la órbita terrestre a
36.000 kilómetros de distancia y no
puede enviar cargas más pesadas al
espacio ya tardé debido a los retrasos
en las entregas del lanzador arian 6
revistas para finales de 2023 los
europeos no tienen ninguna solución a
corto plazo para lanzar sus satélites en
un mercado en rápida expansión